unicén sean muchas gracias por su
presencia en france 24 preguntarle en
primer lugar qué consecuencias considera
usted que podría tener la muerte de word
en este momento tan particular no para
la escena política de eeuu a casi dos
meses de las elecciones presidenciales
la primera consecuencia que tiene es a
corto plazo y es con la campaña
presidencial en este momento se activan
los dos partidos a la luz de esta
noticia el partido republicano tratando
de buscar un reemplazo y el y también
buscando activar a las mujeres
conservadoras que son una votación
importante para esta elección de mujeres
conservadoras que no están de acuerdo
con algunos fallos recientes de la corte
suprema y les gustaría ver una corte de
muchísimo más conservadora con respecto
a los temas sociales y culturales y a
los demócratas activando también
movimientos de mujeres movimientos de
aquellos que están buscando un
equilibrio importante que tiene la corte
suprema en la democracia de eeuu
ha creado un nuevo oxígeno en estas
últimas semanas de campaña y desde su
punto de vista quien debería ser donald
trump o el presidente que resulte electo
en noviembre quien no mire al sucesor de
la sucesora de guinzburg creo que lo más
importante es entender que el equilibrio
ideológico en la corte ha sido un punto
clave en la política de eeuu siempre en
la historia de las instituciones de eeuu
y el hecho de que se politice en un
nombramiento de esta naturaleza en medio
de una campaña es inconveniente en ese
sentido estaría completamente de acuerdo
con aplazar la la nominación hasta
después de las elecciones pero trump que
está en medio de la campaña pues tiene
toda la razón en tratar de apurar la
nominación viendo que tiene el senado a
su favor y que está en las condiciones
óptimas políticas así que es una guerra
política ya quisiéramos que esperara
hasta después de las elecciones ahora su
eventual reemplazo podría inclinar no la
corte hacia una tendencia todavía más
conservadora de la que tiene x
consecuencias podría tener esto teniendo
en cuenta el momento tan particular que
está atravesando a eeuu no con masiva
manifestación
en todo el país anti raciales contra la
violencia policial y que dividen a la
sociedad estadounidense
se va a dividir aún más en este momento
lo que está en la mesa y lo que la corte
suprema en este momento representa para
eeuu es un equilibrio con respecto a los
temas sociales los temas de justicia
racial de matrimonio gay en la guerra
cultural el aborto etcétera y una corte
de completamente conservadora como
quedaría sin hacer una nominación donald
trump realmente va a retroceder 40 años
de este país